hi i'm lindsey and i'm here to talk
about amazon prime video's new series
the wilds and
which character i relate to the most
okay so here's the dealio so the show's
about a group of teenage girls who are
flying to an all-girls retreat when they
find themselves
crash-landed on a deserted island
[Applause]
in addition to the crazy premise the
diverse cast of characters is the real
draw to the show
let's break them down may i just say i
am ready to make the call so the first
episode is about leah we see her back in
the real world where she meets her
favorite author
so they have a little romance and then
yikes he finds out that she's been lying
about her age and is way younger than he
thought you're a child
and lied to me
[Music]
dgaf i don't even get feminism i get
called a girly girl like it's a bad
thing
there's a hole never have i ever seen
and found puts all of her fingers down
she's fierce and she knows it i mean i'm
not a freak shelby
shelby is a good southern girl i do
family i do jesus i do pageants she's a
beauty queen
a leader pragmatic and practical in the
interest of bringing us all together i'd
like to propose a little icebreaker but
as put together as she appears i get the
feeling that there's something below the
surface that
she's trying to hide yeah well i've also
shut down a 10-point buck
then there's martha martha despite being
on the plane with her best friend from
her reservation
tony martha and shelby hit it off
immediately does anyone ever told you of
the most drop dead gorgeous eyes
martha's pretty chill she absolutely
destroys her ankle and
is pretty low-key about it i'm fine
seriously which
not like me at all i would be screaming
so tony tony is martha's best friend and
does not trust shelby
at all am i right you know i'm right she
might be a teeny bit jealous because
shelby's taking all of her friend's
attention
but she's only looking out for her
friend martha who she's worried about
and then there's nora nora is super
sweet and super quiet but also
really smart you're smart huh i just
read a lot she's kind of lucky in the
fact that she's the only one on this
island who is family with her
her sister rachel but she's kind of
unlucky that she's stuck
with her sister rachel on the island you
were treating me like a child like you
always do i mean that's why we're here
right true that's not true
yes it is rachel is an elite diver she
is seriously driven
so driven that she's pushed herself
dangerously to do well at this point
people waste their talent get on my
nerves
she is the most motivated to get off
this island because she has a shot at
the olympics
and that's not gonna happen if she's
stuck on the sidelines one bar and
almost zero battery life left
every second count and then there's
jeanette she's a fun loving optimist who
loves popcorn and guess who i listen to
most especially pink
my play count says i like pink
[Music]
she has a rate of non-stop sunshine
and then there's dot that is the person
you'd want to be on a deserted island
with
you gotta get up and move around right
you're in shock she calls herself
resourceful af books man can't get into
him
because she is but like your phone's
right there i've got a few questions
about your cargo pants just like storage
she's also the person i would put
money on to stay sane in this situation
because she has seen
some [ __ ] thanks dude so
who am i most like i would say batten
definitely fadden puts fashion first
even when it comes to a deserted island
she's always looking
so good she somehow ended up on this
island with her
whole suitcase of designer clothing and
as heavy as [ __ ] i don't know if that's
admirable or just cool
i would definitely do that too she's
super unapologetic with everything she
says
and she keeps her chill which to be
honest maybe isn't me but
i admire it in her that's poetic guys i
want to know what character you're the
most like
so comment down below and let me know
who you choose you try to figure
us out there is no crazy there's only
damage and when you go looking for what
caused it don't
waste your time on that island don't
forget to binge watch amazon prime
videos the wilds on december 11th
and if you're not a member already you
can activate a free trial and watch the
wilds along with other amazing amazon
originals and series